♪
Ty: Do you know what the greatest thing about America is?
Ty: You can make things happen here like no where else.
♪
Ty: You have the power to create your own future.
Ty: You can be anything. You can do anything.
♪
Employee: You want to sell
high end stuffed Himalayan cats?
Ty: Under stuffed actually, for greater possibility.
Robbie: We’re professionals,
we’re giving the people what they need.
♪
Ty: Did you see the latest numbers?
We broke the entire internet thing!
♪
Ty: You go big
or you go home!
[CHEERING]
♪
Robbie: Ty would tell you he did it all
[GASPS]
♪
Robbie: Which is as crazy as
Robbie: believing stuffed animals are gold.
[TIRES SCREECHING]
Ty: Did you see the truck crash?
[BANG]
[HONKING]
Insane.
[LAUGHTER]
Poor beanies.
♪
Ty: This has always been my company.
A company we created together.
Why do you have to be dramatic, I mean?
My salary’s been reduced 75 percent.
Yeah I’m just doing what’s necessary.
You know, running the real actual business over here.
♪
Maya: My life is this company.
Maya: I see where it’s going.
♪
Maya: There are signs of real trouble.
Ty: Genius is 1 percent inspiration,
99 percent presentation.
That’s not how the saying goes.
[GROANS]
♪
Ty: Everything good that’s happened to me
Ty: is because of you guys.
Ty: We are bonded forever.
♪
Have you considered poisoning him?
Countless times.
♪
[LAUGHING]
Ty: I have our perfect partners lined up
Jehovah’s witnesses.
The greatest 101 salesmen in the world.
How brilliant is that?
[EXHALES]
♪
Maya: It’s all gonna go boom!
You’re dead to me!
♪
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey.
Has she reached out?
♪